Hallo meine Lieben!
Heute gibt's etwas Leckeres. Ich bin ganz ehrlich zu euch: I don't know - ich weiß nicht, wie man es nennt!
Weil das gab's halt immer, ne? Das gab's halt zwischendurch mal und dann hieß es bei uns immer
Kıyma ile ekmek oder Kıyma ile börek, das heißt halt
Brot oder Börek mit Hackfleisch.
(H: Was ist das für ein Zungenbrecher ey?)
Ja für mich nicht, für dich vielleicht!
(H: *imitiert türkische Laute*)
Auf jeden Fall mache ich jetzt hier erst mal einen Teig ohne Hefe, das ist kein Hefeteig und -
(H: Ja aber was wird dann drin sein? Hackfleisch?)
Ja ich - ja, Hackfleisch!
Ich bin dabei, ich bin dabei! So und das ist halt ein Teig - nee, das ist Hackfleisch umhüllt von Teig,
was dann in der Pfanne gebacken wird und oh mein Gott, es ist so
knusprig von außen und innen kommt euch dann dieses zarte Fleisch entgegen, lecker gewürzt!
Und das ist so ein Rezept: ihr seht das Bild und jeder, egal wer wird sagen: "Oh mein Gott ich kenne das,
das ist so lecker!"
(H: Ja!)
Nur wie nennt man's? Schreibt's mir mal in die Kommentare,
dann kann ich den Titel ja dementsprechend umändern!
Und ich fange jetzt einfach mal an. Ich habe jetzt hier die Küchenmaschine, ihr könnt auch eure Hände benutzen,
gar kein Thema!
Ich hab jetzt hier Mehl drinnen, geb da Salz mit dazu und der Teig besteht aus nur 4 Zutaten.
und ich lasse jetzt - ich muss kurz schlucken, ich hab zu viel geredet!
Und ich hab jetzt, genau -
(H: Ach du wolltest wieder schummeln, ne?)
Ich hab jetzt Mehl und Salz drin, lass die jetzt so langsam langsam verkneten mit dem Knethaken
und geb dann nach und nach immer wieder ein bisschen lauwarmes Wasser rein.
Dann verbindet sich das einfach besser wenn das Wasser lauwarm ist und dann dürft ihr -
ja, so einen Teig erhalten, der darf nicht klebrig sein sondern schön geschmeidig
und gerade so fest. Und anschließend gebt ihr auch noch ein bisschen Rapsöl dazu.
Die Maschine hat jetzt den teig ca 2min geknetet und ich habe jetzt noch ungefähr 1 - 1 ½min
auf der Arbeitsfläche weitergemacht. Ihr braucht nicht viel Öl, ihr braucht auch nicht viel Wasser.
Ich schreibe euch natürlich alle genauen Mengenangaben unten in die Infobox.
Die findet ihr neben dem Titel, da fragen nämlich immer ganz viele.
Und genau - den Teig, den forme ich jetzt quasi zu einer Kugel, so ganz grob
und gebe ihn zurück in meine Schüssel.
Der muss jetzt nicht wirklich aufgehen sondern eher entspannen, das ist ganz wichtig.
Dafür gebe ich ein bisschen Backtrennspray in die Schlüssel, leg den Teig rein,
benetze auch die Oberfläche damit damit's eben nicht austrocknet, dann den Deckel drauf
und ca 45min lang ruhen lassen. Ich zeige euch aber in der Zwischenzeit die Hackfleischfüllung.
Für die Hackfleischfüllung habe ich jetzt hier mein Hackfleisch in eine
ausreichend große Schüssel gegeben.
(H: Mach's gleich kaputt!)
Tschuldigung! So und da gebe ich jetzt Gewürze mit dazu.
Ich hab hier einmal Kreuzkümmel, ich finde Kreuzkümmel und Hackfleisch
passt einfach wie die Faust auf das Auge!
Einmal da rein. Dann habe ich hier Paprikapulver edelsüß
(H: *lacht* Was für'n Beispiel!)
Paprikapulver  edelsüß und ein bisschen Chili aber nur ein bisschen weil ihr wisst ja:
Hamza und ich wir sind immer noch hm..
(H: Wir sind Weicheier.)
Wir sind immer noch Weicheier, wir können das nicht mit so viel Scharf!
Natürlich Salz mit rein und frisch gemahlenem Pfeffer und dann gebe ich noch Zwiebeln dazu,
ich habe jetzt hier zufällig rote Zwiebeln da gehabt. Und was ganz wichtig ist,
das gibt noch mal so einen leckeren Twist: Petersilie. Das habe ich aber vorab mit meinem Wiegemesser
noch mal fein verarbeitet. Je feiner desto besser finde ich! Und dann verkneten wir das einfach.
(H: *lacht* Wo kommt das denn her?)
Na aus meiner Bauchtasche!
Ja manchmal mag ich es mit Handschuhen zu arbeiten und manchmal einfach ohne!
So, das Hackfleisch habe ich jetzt auch nur eine Minute durchgeknetet.
Und ihr braucht auch kein zusätzliches Bindemittel! Ich nehme mir jetzt so einen Hackfleischball,
ich bereite mir jetzt hier einfach mal einen vor um euch das zu zeigen.
Unser Teig konnte auch entspannen und das teilt ihr euch jetzt einfach ein.
Ich sage euch am Ende wie viele Teiglinge ich rausbekommen hab.
Wie Kaugummi ist der Teig, also richtig perfekt! Der reißt euch auch nicht.
(H: Ich wollt's auch gerade sagen: der reißt gar nicht, ne?)
Nee, gar nicht, total perfekt!
(H: Echt gut!)
(H: Das ist doch voll rund jetzt!)
Mh, es ist noch rund, es ist noch dick - du weißt was wir machen, ne?
(H: Aber das sind doch Kugeln!)
Normalerweise weiß Hamza nie was ich filme, erst wenn wir ganz am Ende angekommen sind
aber du hast es richtig erkannt! Die sind-
(H: Weil ich weiß, wie das Endergebnis ist, deshalb wundere ich mich gerade!)
Genau und das Endergebnis ist eher flach und das sind ja eher dicke runde Kugeln
und deswegen schnappt ihr euch jetzt euer Nudelholz
und geht da ganz vorsichtig drüber!
(H: Ahhhh!)
So, ich sprühe die Arbeitsfläche mit Backtrennspray weil der Teig sonst auf der Arbeitsfläche klebt
und dann bekommt ihr eben Risse. Und der Teig ist aber so geschmeidig, dass ihr eigentlich gar keine Risse
bekommen solltet! So, ich bereite jetzt alle vor
und anschließend werden sie in einer gut beschichteten Pfanne mit etwas Raps- oder Sonnenblumenöl
ausgebacken von beiden Seiten, das zeige ich euch aber gleich in aller Ruhe.
So, jetzt habe ich in meiner beschichteten Pfanne ein bisschen Öl und hab die mittlere Stufe eingestellt,
lieber ein bisschen niedriger als zu hoch weil wir wollen jetzt, dass die äußere Hülle schön knusprig wird,
nicht zu dunkel und dass das Fleisch innen gart.
Und das schmeckt einfach so lecker. Es ist auch nochmal ein Unterschied ob ihr das Fleisch vorher
an...brät? Anbratet?
Oder ob ihr das halt in dieser Kruste garen lasst. Das ist ein Riesenunterschied und es schmeckt nochmal
ganz ganz anders! Ich hab jetzt hier genug Platz, ich geb jetzt hier 3 oder 4 Stück davon rein.
Und dann immer wieder wenden,  also wirklich immer wieder dabei bleiben, nicht weggehen!
Und im besten Falle auch zwischendurch den Deckel drauf machen damit diese Hitze wirklich innen drin bleibt
und das Fleisch auch schön garen kann.
(H: Damit es schön schwitzen kann!)
Genau!
Also ihr müsst euch für eine Ladung schon so 8-10min Zeit nehmen, immer wieder  wenden,
immer wieder ein Auge drauf halten und wenn sie so aussehen, dann sind sie perfekt.
Jetzt nehme ich sie einmal raus und back die nächsten aus.
Und jetzt ist das Fleisch auch richtig schön gar und es - wie ich schon gesagt habe - es gart einfach anders
in diesem Teigmantel. Es ist ganz anders als wenn ihr das eben direkt in der Pfanne anbratet,
also es ist mega mega lecker und außen eben sehr knusprig.
So wenn euch das Rezept jetzt sehr gut gefallen hat - genauso wie uns -
dann hinterlasst meinem Kanal auf jeden Fall ein kostenloses Abo
damit ihr auch die Rezepte nicht mehr verpasst! Ich habe gesehen, dass ganz viele die Glocke nicht
aktiviert haben. Wir laden ja ab und zu auch mal ein drittes Video die Woche hoch
und wenn ihr die Glocke aktiviert, dann bekommt ihr das auch mit!
Und ansonsten würde ich sagen an alle Studenten, die keinen Backofen haben:
Macht's unbedingt nach, sehr sehr sehr lecker! Außen wie gesagt mega knusprig
und innen dann dieses zarte Fleisch! Wir haben noch ein paar Stunden, dann dürfen wir endlich essen.
Willst du auch noch was sagen?
(H: Ich finde gerade zu Suppe passt das ganz gut.)
Zu Suppe passt das ganz gut, ja das stimmt! Das stimmt, zu Suppe passt das sehr, sehr gut!
Ansonsten außerhalb von Ramadan vielleicht mal zum Frühstück, Schlemmerfrühstück,
also macht's einfach sehr sehr gerne nach!
(H: Abendessen!)
Genaue, zum Abendessen.
So, euch wünsche ich jetzt noch einen wunderschönen Tag
und wir sehen uns beim nächsten Mal auf Kikis Kitchen, Tschüss!